aligning in unstable postures so there's
a belief that you cannot align your body
and still move around the alignment it's
simply not true if i have mic go ahead
and start to push into me what i'm doing
is i'm rooting through to the ground
here and i'm using my bones so my
muscles don't have to do so much work
now even as he's pushing you can see
that i can move my body through this
alignment in lots of ways it's because
as i move my body i'm naturally
redirecting the force i can change my
feet i can put myself in all kinds of
strange positions and still manage to
resist the force now i do have to use
muscle in order to go through these
different positions but i can move
myself in all kinds of ways this is what
happens in a dynamic situation when
you're being pushed and you're using the
alignment of your body to keep the force
away aligning in unusual positions